hey it's betsy from tasty and today i'm
going to tell you about one of my recipe
videos that i didn't expect to go viral
my cinnamon sugar donut cones
i don't want to discourage anyone from
making these but tears were shed behind
the scenes while filming this
i was inspired by these really cool
hungarian chimney cakes the dough is
wrapped around a stick and then baked
over an open fire so i really wanted to
transform this into something that
people could easily make at home and
then up the indulgence factor by coating
the inside with chocolate and topping it
off with some ice cream
making the dough for the cones was the
easy part
but when it came time to wrap the dough
around the aluminum foil and bake the
cones i was like why is the world
against me right now
i kept saying to myself please stay
together don't fall over
don't unravel
all of those things kind of happened
you might not know this but tasty
producers are responsible for cooking
and shooting at the same time so when
you throw food especially ice cream into
the mix things can get a little out of
control sometimes there was chocolate
and ice cream all over my hands all over
the table
cinnamon sugar and rainbow sprinkles all
over the floor
i was just like getting so frustrated
then i thought it would be a great idea
to coat the inside of the cone with
chocolate big mistake i was just worried
that the cones and assembly process
weren't going to look easy and clean
enough to really appeal to our fans i'm
a perfectionist okay there i said it for
this recipe one day of shooting turned
into three days of shooting i almost
lost it i think because i felt
disappointed behind the scenes i thought
the audience would also be disappointed
but i was wrong sometimes there's beauty
in disaster because to my surprise the
recipe was a huge hit on the internet
when i saw this video surpass 30 million
views on facebook i was like
no way
you gotta love those silver linings here
are a couple quick tips if you want to
make these when you're wrapping the
dough around the aluminum foil you
almost want to slightly overlap the
dough you want to make sure that the
seams are sealed and the ends are tucked
in
otherwise the cone could unravel during
baking be very careful when transferring
your cones to the oven the higher walls
of the muffin tin help keep your cones
upright but a couple of mine did topple
over so just keep an eye on them
anyway have fun with it these cones
really are so good i can't thank you
enough for all your support and i can't
wait to make more recipes for you
oh yes
you